I think part of the problem with the classical media,
let's say,
trying to make a transition to the digital age is that they have no idea what
the digital media is.
Like.
I was watching an MSNBC,
a clip the other day about this robot.
I think her name is Sophia,
who,
who has a fairly advanced degree of artificial intelligence and who can manifest
pretty realistic human facial emotions.
And,
uh,
it was a four minute clip and add a 32nd ad at the beginning of it and you
couldn't skip the ad.
And I thought there's a real arrogance on the part of the MBA,
ms NBC people to put that on youtube because anybody who's familiar with the
youtube,
let's say,
culture knows that what you get to put a ten second ad on and then you get to
skip it after five seconds if you want.
Like you can't ask people to pay 30 seconds of attention for four minutes of
content.
It violates the norms.
And so it had only had about 12,000 views.
And that's a really interesting example of Marshall Mcluhan's idea that the
medium is the message,
right?
As you build a new technological infrastructure.
And it's sort of like the old thing because youtube is sort of like a TV
network,
but it's also not like a TV network at all,
partly for example,
because when you put something on Youtube,
it's permanent.
And that's way different than broadcast TV.
Like it's raw,
it's seriously revolutionarily different.
And so,
and it's also the case too,
that this is a strange thing and I don't think the classic media understands
this either,
is that youtube people don't like high production values.
In fact,
they're very cynical about them.
And I think that's because they've come to identify advanced editing and Glitz
as markers that the information is actually being manipulated,
which of course it is now for better or worse.
I mean editing doesn't have to be manipulating,
but it certainly can be.
And so,
and besides that,
a lot of the more tech savvy people that watch youtube can duplicate those sort
of special effects in their own home in half an hour.
So they're not there.
They're no longer markers of the kind of competence and technological prowess
that would signal the sort of competence that you could trust.
So,
so what youtube viewers seem to like is basically ordinary people more or less
trying to have an intelligent conversation about something confusing and
important and the attention span that people are willing to devote to that is
actually quite remarkable for for a medium that was nothing but cute cat videos
say five years ago.
The fact that like a lot of my lectures and like Joe Rogan's podcast like three
hours long,
it's like what the hell?
People weren't supposed to have that capacity to pay attention in this era of
fragmented attention.
You know,
in Rogan,
I don't know if you know this or not,
he has 120 million downloads a month now.
So that's 1.5 billion a year.
And so the last time I saw him,
and that was with Brett who just spoke,
um,
I,
I asked him what it was like to be the most powerful interview or the world has
ever seen because I think he probably is,
if you think about it and sheer numbers.
I mean,
maybe Walter Cronkite back in the 60s had some comparable influence,
but he said,
I just don't think about it.
And we're like,
what,
what the hell is he supposed to think about it?
Because no one knows what to think about that.
And so he just has the conversations and posts them and way he goes,
but he has no idea what role he's currently playing in society and we don't have
proper metrics for measuring it and we don't understand it at all.
So anyways,
I did these big idea lectures with,
with Whoa deck and,
and uh,
they were ranked on,
on,
uh,
the Dvo channel and the five lectures or six lectures I did all ended up in the
top 20,
which really surprised me.
But it was an indication that there was something about what I was talking about
that for which there was a market.
And now there's,
there's some reasons for that.
I think,
you know,
when I.